hey guys I'm Jess here with Tita and
Aaron's joining us as well to talk about
two Sonic games that's right I headed
our way which is super exciting Sonic is
damn classic I'm just gonna ask you a
really simple version with a simple
question before you get into the demo
but what's it like bringing out two new
Sonic games in 2017 it's two classic
classic series it's a little surreal
especially because one of them is such a
big throwback to the 90s and then the
other one is come this evolution of what
sonic have been doing yeah the last 10
years so it's pretty cool
I'm speaking from the perspective of
someone who was a fan you know of Sega
and Sonic growing up in the 90s that was
like my childhood yeah so now kind of
being involved with it is surreal on its
own but then like two games one one for
each kind of audience is also really
really cool yeah that's crazy so like
all right let's let's jump right in I'm
gonna I'm gonna make you a play while
you talk to me cuz that's probably I can
try not easy and definitely nothing will
go wrong
um just don't die never never think ever
goes wrong with life but that's okay um
so you're uh this is Sonic forces so yes
you want it let's talk to the gameplay
of this you've got three different
gameplay styles right that's right so
we've got the modern sonic gameplay
we've got the classic sonic gameplay and
for the first time ever we are allowing
people to create their own custom
character pray hero character and and
when we announced that the internet
rejoiced every certain certain segments
but oh my gosh finally Sardu asking for
pages right we get fan mail I mean every
week of people sending in here's my
character please you know yeah I can
search anything in the word Sonic the
Hedgehog read and you will find all
manner things your your name the
Hedgehog is is a running joke that even
we understand in the Sega office and we
do it should we do it all the time and
have a great laugh yes that's a lot of
Sonic stuff out there half of it
appropriate um so what do you say be
less than half rest enough to be jumping
into fists we'll take a look at modern
sonic first Graham now this is Sonic
forces it's the new game from Sonic Team
it's running on the Hedgehog engine -
it's a brand new engine that they
developed for the next-gen hardware so
there is a lot of beautiful look at the
lighting right oh yeah the lighting I
mean the water effects like oh wow yeah
that kind of stop into the water rushing
in over the cobblestones like little
things that when you're running it
hundred miles per hour you don't
normally see know what what they're
they're terrible ERISA yeah exactly
gold rings of course we're collecting
those and I can like tap the triggers
here to kind of - left and right yeah so
the gameplay feels like an evolution of
two games and in particular that Sonic
Colors you see these wisps here just
like Sonic Colors and also Sonic
Generations right and the reason we
picked those two games is because those
are the ones looking back at Sonic's 3d
titles those ones that are one side well
these are the games we really enjoy
really like yeah and we can boost to go
really fast I'm not gonna boost the
entire level we could but I'm gonna slow
it down to kind of show you guys how
this works
yeah by jumping twice we can homing
attack and enemies just like that we got
the stomp yep and avoid those spikes of
death there I mean I have to ask like
how does the process go with just like
ensuring the gameplay it's like I mean
there's no room for error right with
Sonic like everything goes so fast
everything needs to be so tight I mean
is that like an extreme process of just
like technically making sure it's
perfect it's a really good question
because that's that's been kind of like
the key challenge with Sonic games is
finding the right control and right roll
for Sonic including the classic titles
which we'll get to after her forces with
mania it's so so important to be precise
and to feel like you have full control
over Sonic and the other characters and
that's why one of the things that team
has been working on is like really
getting it right they've evolved the
controls even from from generations and
from colors and then also kind of
adjusted it too so we get the classic
Sonic in a second yeah it doesn't play
just like Classic Sonic did in
generations they've taken the physics
they've enhanced them it a little bit
better those little things that they
keep adding to right and keep the
bombing on what's the the biggest change
in terms of the control control scheme
for this style of stage um probably for
this one I think modern Sonics probably
the least amount of changes of any of
the three if you can play generations
and colors it's a lot like those so I
just played a bit like those and here
we're going to speed to the end of the
level we're gonna meet a familiar face
oh it's shadow as people are asking a
shadow gonna be in the oh yeah confirmed
here at e3 yeah uh he was certainly
making a cameo we got a little results
screen here oh good job
oh just an a-rank that all well yes so
being a being a Japanese about game of
course a series get yeah um so I mean we
talked about it a bit before but like
how
you have this so much expectation
especially like from from a Sonic game
how do you go about managing what fans
want what you want to create like how
does that all balance out that's a great
question and you know there's a lot of
people out there that have very
different tastes
yeah right and Sonic has gone through so
many different iterations over the years
and so many different styles of gameplay
that now you kind of have people that
may like one particular style of game
but maybe not another yeah and so it's a
good question how do you please
everybody and the answer is I don't
think you ever can truly please everyone
but I think the best that you can do is
to try and make a game that is just fun
to play in general yeah you know and
that when people try it to go this is
this is really enjoyable no matter what
kind of game you like and that's kind of
what the team is trying to do here
they've got the classic style for people
that really like that from generations
they've got the modern style from people
to lawn into 3d games and then the
custom character which kind of came out
of nowhere for a lot of the people that
were watching is is an evolution of the
modern sonic style so it's wouldn't want
to call it you know generations - yeah I
didn't want to just say oh we're taking
the exact same physics and controls and
putting those in there and that's where
the custom character comes in to kind of
evolve things and mix it up yeah I mean
I'd love to ask I'm not sure if we'll
get a chance to see it later but how
custom is the custom character um we're
not gonna go into full details here we
took it out of the e3 build because
we're like if we put this if we put this
in the build people can spend 30 minutes
online carry thing they would get tested
exactly sitting there like no no no I'm
still making my character man yeah so we
decide all right we'll just what kind of
randomize a little bit for people and
but you will get to see some I can like
back in and out and show you some
different random characters yeah just a
preset it default and there's seven
different types I guess I'll talk about
those in a second but here's this is
classic Sonic or sitting right here and
we're fighting the egg Dragoon this boss
fight started with him fighting the
original boss almost from Green Hill
Zone we had like the ball and chain this
one was a chainsaw and so then you beat
that boss like oh cool we're done we're
done no no not quite and then you'll get
Phase two which is this this box the egg
Dragoon
so is that a pretty common you know
thing in this game where you introduce a
boss that looks like a classic one and
then it evolved slightly or is it maybe
just this case this is one of the one of
the biggest cases I think but there
might be some other surprises certainly
waiting in store for fans as they go
through there we go we've we've defeated
the egg Dragoon now
excellent good some dial I guess in the
background there you were seeing some
like some sand a little sand waterfalls
or sand falling us in that case was the
technical term for those sand phones
that right uh I'm not a scientist but
let's go let's go back to the scientist
I don't have glasses sample - so you
kind of see the effects of Eggman taking
over on the world that's kind of the
story of this game is that Eggman is
conquered 99% of the world and it's up
to Sonic and Classic Sonic and the
character that you make to kind of fight
back as the uprising and take back the
world from him how do you explain the
three of those coexisting that or at
least even just modern sonic and classic
sonic same well I could go into details
but I would kind of spoil things so in
order to not spoiled story and because I
knew a lot of Sonic fans are gonna be
watching and listening to this yeah I'm
going let's go over every single word
that we get as an answer I don't wanna
spoil it yeah but we will explain that I
promise you it will be accessible as its
addressed yes I 100 well what can you
tell us about story well that's kind of
the key thing that we've revealed so far
the Eggman has taken over the world he's
done it with the help of a brand new
villain that we revealed in our e3
trailer and that villains name is
infinite right and not much is know
about infinite except that there's also
other villains making return shadows one
of them Kaos from Sonic Adventure making
an appearance Metal Sonic and Ziva from
Sonic lost world so kind of this
all-star cast the villains showing up
what we're seeing here is our is our
custom character Italy so I can back out
and show you guys actually let's go with
this let's do so we've got two different
choice of wisp ons yeah responds our
gadgets that allow us to not only go on
the offense against enemies but also to
platform in the level so we can do the
burst or the lightning I'm gonna do the
burst and show you what's that one so I
assumed there's gonna be a lot of those
in thee definitely more than two quite a
few more than two they go you had it on
your buffers heard it here first folks
that's quote can the news team get on
that that'd be good yeah I'm will be
waiting for the headline to say gherkin
arms awesome so what are we looking at
here we're looking at this is the
side-scrolling part of the custom
character gameplay and just like with
modern sonic we'll be going between the
two DS kind of sides and the 3d over the
shoulder kind of camera by grabbing one
of these responds so now on the
bottom-left my meter is filled up and I
can push the triangle button here to
start boosting
there we go
and I can launch myself through the air
and by picking up more of these as we're
going through okay well there we go
it'll keep refilling and I can just use
that to launch myself through the level
can't leave that registering there we go
so with these extra abilities I'm
actually curious like if you can make a
custom character that is actually look
that looks like Sonic and and then you
know in essence play as Sonic with these
responds you can you can get close Wow
you'll know you can't make an exact
clone of Sonic but you can you can have
fun we've uh in the office we've been
going through and making characters that
was close to certain Sonic memes as
possible to see to see like can it be
done you know very edgy looking
characters and yeah you can you can get
pretty creative with it your character
will also show up in the cutscenes of
the game whenever your your character so
you know go little around it can be
pretty fun watching your character run
around yeah great so I mean it was it
just was it the right time now you were
just like the fans want it and we're in
a place where it makes sense to make it
to include this is an option yeah and I
think I think sonic team have been kind
of mulling this over for a long time and
kind of wanting to include something
like this and the opportunity came up
and with you know the next-gen hardware
it made a lot of sense to kind of add
this in and to see what people thought
and based on the reaction we've seen so
far this there's a lot of very excited
people but I think the cool thing about
it really is that you don't have to
necessarily be what I would call a
superfan to appreciate the character
creator you don't have to be the person
you know on deviantART posting your fan
art every day to like it you can take it
seriously you can just be really silly
with it it's totally up to you yeah how
much do these levels different from the
classic stages otherwise Oh what you're
seeing right here this version of green
hills on the level layout all of that
was brand new um this is kind of in the
setting of Green Hill Zone as it's been
taken over by Eggman but everything that
we're playing is brand new and different
I'm gonna kind of dodge these I'm really
nervous right now what's he doing I'm
like hit the buttons everything's
totally fine I promise maybe probably
will dodge these there we go that's a
that's very threatening yeah just a
little bit I know we're gonna do who
okay almost there
we're gonna wait for that target to go
over the circle perfect hey all right
I think that's the first perfect that s
right
we're going for it huh we'll wrap the
grappling hook there around the legs of
that giant enemy and then here we got a
little cinematic moment and so it's it's
important from the team's perspective to
make sure that people really enjoy
playing all three types in the game and
so you've got that modern styling people
like that you've got classic sonic and
then you've got the evolution of the
gameplay which is hopefully gonna be an
s-rank here let's see eh
oh come on please oh wait wait wait I
believe in you Oh Eric I spent much time
talking very upsetting
oh it's our fault that was your mistake
interview that's been to the bosses in
Japan I am very sorry I have shamed you
please forgive me oh well I would like
to ask I mean obviously like we've grown
up with Sonic yeah sorry I mean for us
it's like it's such a it's a nostalgic
thing it's revisiting like our childhood
how do you see this game appealing to
kids teenagers who didn't grow up it's
like yeah it what's fun because you
would think and this is like the
perspective that we've got from from our
generation maybe we grew up with it
we're like oh cool maybe there's this
big gap between ourselves and a new
generation of Sonic fans there's
actually not necessarily and what I
would have learned in my time in the
Sonic community is that there is this
continuing evolution of people that came
into it kids that came into it when they
were 12 or when they were 10 right maybe
their first game was Sonic Adventure
their first game was Sonic Heroes or
even Sonic Generations one of my
favorite stories is that I met a kid in
New York Comicon once and he was
probably like eight years old and we
were demoing a Sonic game there and I
was like oh you know nice nice to meet
you what's your favorite Sonic game and
I was expecting the kid to tell me you
know one of the more recent sonic games
generations or yeah yeah yeah
and he looked at me and without any
hesitation he's like Sonic 2 what and I
was like that game was like 10 years
before you were born like is what's
going out of my mind and and it was a
good moment kind of for me to realize
that there's a lot of kids out there
that are growing up and playing Sonic
games are even discovering the Sonic
games from years past and appreciating
them and enjoying them and so it's kind
of neat
that's funny well that leads us on to a
really good good point because sonic
mania is yeah I mean you're Alyssa do we
have a demo to crack into on that one
yeah we actually I think we've got some
some alley footage to show off ok well
that's right to that and it will do
so um well okay well this obviously
looks very different so with a classic
here we do recession to the classic and
this was made with the fence in
collaboration with with the the people
who love something separate that's right
that's right so this is sonic mania it's
a brand new 2d adventure you can see
from what what's on the screen there
this is a very retro sonic title it's
pretty much what would have happened had
sonic games continued on in 2d you know
on the Sega Saturn maybe in like
nineteen ninety five or six yeah and the
people that are making this the reason
it looks so good the reason that the
physics are so perfect is because the
people making it they were fans growing
up exactly right and then they've become
professional developers yeah and so now
they're really good programmers or
coders or level designers or musicians
and you have this kind of all-star team
that's come in now and they're making
this game and it's it's just kind of
amazing because they put so much effort
into it and there's so many little
Easter eggs in there but at the same
time because it's a 2d sonic game it's
so easy to just get lost in it or I
haven't played a Sonic game in a long
time to pick up the controller and go oh
I just I run around I get gold rings you
know and I run to the end of the level
and that's the simplicity of classic
Sonic is very appealing to me personally
yeah I've read the people contributing
to this I also sort of based like all
over the world yeah one of one of the
the lead developers Christian Whitehead
is in Australia yeah one of our Leo's oh
yeah there you go one of our lead
artists in fact two of our artists are
from the UK yeah a lot of our developers
are up in Seattle that's pagoda West
those guys are all up in Seattle one of
the musicians on the East Coast that's T
Lopes so we've got people all around the
world yeah that are contributing to this
and making it happen it's kind of it's
neat but it's also such a kind of
magical moment because yeah all right so
so bear with me here with Japanese
publishers I've mention this before but
Jeffrey's publishers in some cases are
not cool with fan projects yeah yeah
yeah and we don't have to look far to
find examples like that and we're out
today right and so for for Sega to you
to come out and not only say this is a
cool fan project but but we would like
to work with you guys and officially
make a project with you guys I was I was
kind of a little bit in disbelief when I
first heard that this was greenlit it
was actually happening at that moment I
big fluttering of your heart we're like
this really this is a thing
now you know and we were we were all so
excited but I'm just really pleased that
Sega took that stance and was open to
doing that and I'm hoping that the other
publishers someday will also kind of
look to their fans and and maybe mania
can be kind of a case study
fingers crossed someday for it for why
you should embrace the passion of your
hands in distilled saying the customer's
always right
you know so want to empower the customer
in that sense to you know give things
back yeah yeah exactly and you know and
there's some times to like your
customers your fans might have lots of
crazy ideas yeah as you can always
please everyone or you know get
stretched too thin with a million you
know 80 different features and
customization options in your game but
you know these guys they know what makes
classic sonic work right yeah rub with
it right they they spent their lives
going through this stuff and playing it
and they have that level of attention to
detail that you just you won't find that
when you get other devs that you might
just hire to be like oh you know what
will how are you guys to make a classic
game for us they wouldn't put that same
level of dedication or passion into it
these guys are gonna put in just because
they love it so a little teasing like
the nuance things right like those
little things make a big difference
it is like weird this is chemical plant
zone act - yeah and and the game itself
is a mix of classic levels and brand-new
levels right okay the cool thing knows
that the classic levels Act one of the
classic levels is maybe a bit like what
you remember we kind of took the
original act one to squish them together
into the Act one and mainly I like for
chemical plant and for Green Hill Zone
but when you get to the end of that you
can a to you get to this totally new
level you've never seen it before you've
never played it before and we're pretty
excited like with chemical plants on
it's a good example to see what people
think when they see just how different
these levels have become it's very
nostalgic on one hand but also very
unique and very new yeah are there any
other modern elements that we can see
here like a what was it like managing
the collision of like wanting to kind of
refresh but at the same time I mean
you're reinventing a classic so alright
you want to hold on to that
yeah and that's that's it's a good
question because for in that case I
think the team wanted to on one hand
stay true to what classic sonic was and
you'll see that here the physics when
you play the game everywhere t3 is
played it goes oh it feels just like I
remember it memorize him for that like
Christian the lead developer rebuilt the
physics from the original Sonic games by
hand in his own engine because the
emulators just weren't good and ya go
very few other developers would put that
kind of passion into it so on one hand
they want to stay true to that on the
other hand they don't want you to have
the same sonic remaster that you've
played you know time and time again over
the last X amount of years right and so
that's the exciting part I think to me
personally watching this from from the
fan perspective even internally Sega is
going this is really cool kind of to see
this come together to see the new things
they're adding there's Knuckles climbing
right there yeah I mean it looks
gorgeous
I think one of the main things I wanted
to ask was I mean there are a ton of
sonic games and there are a handful that
have not been well-received shall we say
um but that's it there's a lot of
positivity like that I've heard like
particularly from my friends from Sonic
fans who are really excited about the
way these two games look how does it
feel like is there an element of
pressure to be like oh okay everyone's
expecting a lot like people are like
these are gonna be great sonic games
like how does the team feel with that
that kind of fan expectation feedback
it's the first off I just want to say
Sonic 2006 was the best Sonic game ever
okay okay sorry I pick it okay I paid I
paid $60 for Sonic 2006 when I was in
college and I remember that experience
very well I was afraid to that game no
not at all hey it had good music I tell
her it's like a head it had good music
and there's there's certainly been
moments in the past at where certain
sonic games definitely did not live up
to like the quality bar that a lot of us
as fans and his gamers really wanted to
be at and thankfully Sega has taken a
very different approach over the last
few years they started with sonic boom
Fire & Ice
which state which they delayed to kind
of add some more stuff into not like
mania even yeah we pushed out until
August it was going to come out earlier
this year but we looked at it we knew we
can make this game even better with a
little more time like it's already good
but with even more time it can be even
better and so in that that great debate
of do you release a game early or do you
give it the time that it needs a little
extra time to bake to be you know 5 10
percent better right so you like this
deck you see this is so cool okay so
this is Mirage saloon this is one of
those brand new levels that's talking
about this one called studi applets that
we open
with long ago when we first announced
the game it's like a Hollywood inspired
level this is a desert inspired level
and a little bit of trivia on this okay
there was a desert level planned in
Sonic 2 and never happened and so
Christian Whitehead I was making the
sonic CD mobile remaster for for that
for the Sonic CD game and he was trying
to put the desert level back in as like
a sonic CD thing throw that reference in
there and they said no like we can't do
it there's no time we can't do it so
sonic mania gets greenlit and I think
one of the first things probably on
Christians mind as we are making that
desert level happen it is going to ask
game and thus Mirage saloon was born so
yeah there's there's a lot of fun
history to this and they've built all of
this is like it's brand-new there's
these little launchers that he can use
the fire yep there we go
you know you said you know sonic
continued into the Sega Saturn era that
was yak CD Sega Saturn like I'm a big
mintage game collector and player and
Sega Saturn is currently my favorite
system and to see that sprites of this
scale and like the classics or like
rotating effect it's yeah yeah like this
is I I wish you could play on my Saturn
sickly enough but I can't wait to
actually be this on kids for fun fact
we've actually been demoing it sometimes
with Saturn pads EXA like USB side yeah
yes yeah yeah and that's so it's it's
it's a neat moment there the sprites you
just talk about sprites those have all
been updated so yeah I can definitely
give the animation the extra frames in
there it got like just a little bit
enough to be like that seems weird but
like also better yeah they've added
they've added animations in like the
game runs at 60 frames per second which
is great for a Sonic game a lot of the
originals ran pretty close to that but
the animations didn't always flow quite
as smoothly and so they've gone in and
the artists went to lead artists is name
is Tom he's gone through he built that
opening animation where sonic jumps up
by the logo and spins around right built
out over two weeks before the
announcement of the game probably didn't
sleep much and so they've got in to all
the sprites and just updated everything
the running animation has more frames
the idle animations are new like all of
it's been touched up yeah and so that's
that's kind of the really the case of
the entire game we want people to
understand that every single level in
Sonic mania is a new level that you
haven't seen before you get the Green
Hill Zone Act one and the first ten
seconds you go oh I've seen this yeah
and then 20 seconds later you go wait
there's a spring there that wasn't there
and you take the spring you go there's a
new upper path that wasn't here or you
go below and you if it's a cavern area
that's never used
you know in the original Green Hill Zone
on Sonic 1 and it's that level of detail
that they're putting into every single
stage and there's even more that we
haven't talked about yet and we're kind
of doing it on purpose yeah you know we
don't want to spoil everything for
people but since it's coming out in a
couple months we're at that point now
where we're going
all right we're wrapping it up we're
putting the final layers of polish on
there testing everything and it's almost
ready to go so what's gonna happen when
this becomes wildly popular people are
like we want Sonic mania to in my
opinion that's that's if you if you
really want a Sonic mania to the best
thing you can do is buy as many copies
of Sonic will speak you think with your
wallets there and it's hard it's hard
for Sega to not hear that yeah as any
any company right um
so that's that man I'm I'm a super fan
of all of this kind of 2d stuff and it's
really Sonic in general and and that's
why it's such kind of such a privilege
to get to watch this come together and
to watch what the teams are making it's
it's kind of a stork moment yeah
especially this year with these two
games coming out and for the first
project we've ever partnered with fans
on and that's why it's like fingers
crossed but I'm also so excited yeah I
mean I don't think we're all excited
like I'm so happy for you guys I'm so
happy for Sonic they both look like
incredible games and I know we're just
waiting for them to come out the good
news is that Sonic mania comes out on
August 15th so it's only a couple months
away easy so yes all right that'll tide
us over then but that will get you
starting and it's only gonna be $19.99
all right that was a big thing we we we
knew we could have priced it probably a
fair bit higher but we thought let's
make this an amazing price to go with an
amazing game and this will be kind of
the thing that people jump into they go
this is such a great deal you know and I
really love it we've got the collector's
edition to that we put a little
infomercial like in 90s without
infomercial out there yeah and and that
did very well and so this is like a big
statue you get with that one yeah but
the game is false only 1999 and the
pre-orders are up as far as sonic forces
goes that's coming on the holiday summer
going will come out in August and then
you know a little bit later end of the
year sonic forces will come out both
games coming out on pretty much every
platforms
PC ps4 Xbox one and intend to switch
yeah awesome
well playing a look forward to plenty of
places to play it on thanks so much for
joining us Aaron thanks for ah we will
be back soon so
don't go away